مستمرون معكم مشاهدينا في هذه التغطيه
للتطورات في السودان حيث اعلنت الصحه
السودانيه ارتفاع عدد قتل الاشتباكات بين
الجيش والدعم السريع الى 460 قتيلا فضلا
عن اصابه اكثر من 4000 اخرين ياتي ذلك في
وقت تبدل فيها الجيش وقوات الدعم السريعه
الاتهامات بشان خرقه هدنه ثلاثه ايام التي
تم الاعلان عنها بوساطه امريكيه
[موسيقى]
امنه ما في ترادونا من سودان
ناكل ونشربه شيء
كثير وما نقدر نرجع قدام هذه حاجات
ولانهم اكل ولا شرف
كنا مخاطر وكده
وضرب شديد حاصل هناك
في ضرب في الطريق وفي اتوبيسات اتضربت
وكده
اجلت الامم المتحده المئات من موظفيها
العاملين في السودان مع عائلاتهم واوضح
مراسل العربيه في السودان ان عمليه
الاجلاء تمت عبر ميناء
اكد المبعوث الخاص للامم المتحده في
السودان انا مهمه اجلاء المئات من موظفي
الامم المتحده من السودان كانت صعبه
فلنستمع لمقالها
اذا سنستمع لما قاله بعد قليل مشاهدينا
اكمل معكم حيث اكدت
الناطقه باسم الخارجيه الفرنسيه للعربيه
ان باريس تدعو الى وقف اطلاق النار لاسباب
انسانيه محذره من المواجهات الدائره في
السودان التي قد تؤدي الى صدمه اقليميه
وزعزع لاستقرار المنطقه
ايضا
لا وقف اطلاق النار في السودان لاسباب
انسانيه السودان كان دوله هشه على الصعيد
الانساني مع وجود نحو اربعه ملايين نازح
قبل هذه الازمه ثلث سكان السودان لهم
احتياجات انسانيه يجب تجنب حصول صدمه
اقلاميه تزعزع استقرار المنطقه وتؤثر على
الدول المجاوره مفوضيه اللاجئين اشارت الى
وجود عدد كبير من النازحين داخل السودان
اضافه الى لاجئين من الذين اجتازوا الحدود
مع تشاد وهذا سيضغط على الدول المجاوره
على الصعيد الانساني
كما قال تناطق باسم الخارجيه الفرنسيه
معقده بعض الشيء وكان من المفترض انتم بعد
الحصول على ضمانات لاجلاء نحو 500 شخص من
السودان نستمع مجددا لمقالته
انها عمليه معقده ميدانيا ودبلوماسيا
لانها جرت فيما يتواصل القتال في السودان
كان يجب القيام بسلسله اتصالات تسمح
باعطاء نظمانات امنيه لاجلاء حوالي 500
شخص من السودان كما هو معلوم تمكنا من
اجلاء رعايانا والطاقم الدبلوماسي وايضا
اجلين عددا كبيرا جدا من الرعايه الاجانب
في السودان
مراسله العربيه كانت قد رصدت الاجواء في
منطقه المعموره جنوبيه الخرطوم حيث يحاول
المواطنون وبعض الاجانب مغادره العاصمه
هربا من المعا
رك والله
هنمشي مصر
[موسيقى]
في العيش بقى في اي حاجه حتى الاندومي
الحاجه البسيطه
في الشارع من بيتنا الثاني داخله على شقتي
الرصاص
سكينه الدعامه بنص الحله الرصاص تحت
كرعينا يعني امام معدوم كده
مسافرين الاسره كلها
وغير المش قدامي يعني
يعني
بمثابه 300% او اكثر
مشاهدينا لنقل الصوره من على الارض ينضم
الينا من الخرطوم مراسل العربيه سالم
الهاشمي سالم يعني وضع الهدنه الان هل
مازلنا نتحدث عن التزام على الاقل يعني
ليس كامل ولكن التزام
حقيقي بهذه الهدنه وعمليات الاجلاء من
هناك كيف تتم
بالنسبه للهدنه الهدنه الان تشهد هدوءا
نسبيا بعد يوم حدثت فيه العديد من متعلقه
بتبادل اطلاق النار يضاف الى ذلك سماع
لاصوات مختلفه من المدافع الثقيله
والخفيفه ايضا استخدام لمقذوفات في مناطق
متفرقه من الخرطوم ايضا كانت هناك طائرات
تحلق القوات الجويه السودانيه
وكذلك من احداث متفرقه حدثت في الاماكن
التي كانت تتجدد فيها الاشتباكات عدم
مواقع باتت جديده وصلت بعض الشظايا من
مناطق متفرقه
لك اصابه مستشفى في ام درمان بشضيه من
الشظ التي اطلقت لم يعرف سعد من الذي اطلق
هذه طلقه او هذا العيار الناري الذي حدثت
منه
عدد من الاصابات تتجاوز الثلاثه عشر او
خمسه عشر وفيها اصابات خطيره في مستشفى
النوم ومستشفى انضاف الى ذلك اصابات لم
تصل الى المستشفى واصابات خفيفه
او على الاقل حده كذلك
ربما ابرز الاحداث حتى الان لكن هنالك
هدوء نسبي العاصمه الخرطوم مع بعض ايضا
الحركه اللجوء ازدادت وتيرتها اليوم في
مناطق متفرقه التي يخرج منها السكان الى
ولايات وحتى الى جمهوريه مصر العربيه
هنالك
حركه نشطه جدا للجوء والنزوح كذلك
وعن حركه اجلاء للرعايه الاجانب بحركه
الاجلاء للرعايه الاجانب هل هناك رفض يعني
للاعداد التي ممكن ان يتم ايضا اجلاء
بالساعات المقبله هل نتحدث عن فتره زمنيه
طويله لاكمال عمليات هذه الاجلاء
النعم بالنسبه لعمليات الاجلاء طبعا هي
منطقه او قاعده وادي سيدنا التي تقع
الشمال العاصمه الخرطوم في مدينه ام درمان
وهي قاعده جويه تدفع للجيش السوداني هذه
القاعده يتم نهائي الى الرعايه الاجانب
الى مختلف دول العالم وقد بدات منذ يومين
هذه العمليه وماذا لم تستمر ايضا البقيه
كذلك في ميناء السودان والزميل نزار كان
قد رصد العديد من الجاليات التي سيتم
اجلائها من ميناء بورسودان وستتوجه مباشره
الى دولها هذه المساله قد تكفل الجيش
السوداني في اكثر من حديثه على انه ملتزم
باجلاء الرعايه وتوفير الحمايه لهم الى
حين مغادرته
من التزام الجيش السوداني بالبرتقالات
الدوليه المعروفه
عند الحديث عن موضوع الخدمات بشكل عام
ربما موضوع مازال يرابح مكانه في مناطق
متفرقه من العاصمه اشكو فيه السكان من
انقطاع تام للمياه لليوم شرع للتوالي ومما
شكل ازمه حقيقيه في تلك جعلت الكثير من
المواطنين يخرجون من تلك المناطق اللي
يبحثوا عن المياه او يبحثوا عن ماوى اخر
به مياه في داخل العاصمه الخرطوم احياء
عديده جدا
يصعب حصرها حقيقه لانه كل يوم تاتينا
ياتينا جديد في موضوع المياه في مناطق
متفرقه لكن بشكل عام ما زالت صرح مكانها
وما زال ايضا الاتهام متبادل بين في موضوع
المياه لكن تبقى المشكله قائمه حتى الان
مشكله
موضوع الامداد الغذائي ربما حصل انفراد
قليل في بعض المواد الغذائيه وبعض
الامدادات الغذائيه في المناطق في تبعد
قليلا عن مناطق الصراع
نقود كذلك لكنه جزئي ايضا
يضاف الى ذلك الاتصالات وهي مشكله ما زالت
يعني
لانه الاشكال اصبح حتى في موضوع الاتصالات
ليست الانترنت وحده يعني خاصه بعض الشبكات
يصعب فعلا الاتصال هناك اشكال واضح في هذا
الموضوع تذبذب فيها خدمه احيانا تكون
موجوده واحيانا تكون غير موجوده
من مكان لاخر كل هذه مشاكل جديده الى
مشكانات المتعلقه بالاتصالات والتواصل
بشكل عام
ابي موضوع الهجره الداخليه او النزوح
الداخلي للمواطنين السودانيين بالامس كنا
نتحدث عن اكثر من 15 الف فقط نحو الجنوب
اليوم هل هناك اي ارقام او تحديثات حول
ارقام النزوح الداخلي وعلى اطراف على
المناطق يعني الاطراف
نعم بالحديث عن هذا الموضوع نجد صعوبنا
كذلك في الاتصالات التي ذكرتها قبل قليل
للتحديث الارقام لكن بشكل عام ما هو مؤكد
ان عمليات الملوح اليوم ويمكن ان تتزايد
اذا لم الازمه او يلتزم الطرفان بموضوع
الهدنه المعلنه ربما حتى تسهل هذا النزوح
او اللجوء نفسه
تصاحبهم العديد من الاشكاليات في غلاء
التذاكر نفسه توفير الوقود لهذه السفريه
في
من محل اقامتهم الى المكان الذي تتواجد به
هذه البصات التي تقلهم بعد ذلك خارج ولاده
او تطلهم الى دوله مصر مثلا او الى جنوب
السودان
الامور هي معقده يعني مرتبطه ببعضها البعض
من عمليه اللجوء فعلا هي ازمه يشكو ايضا
الغلاء فاحش في الاسعار بالنسبه لتذاكر
النصف
عدم قدرتهم على دفع هذه المبلغ مشكله
التذاكر ومشكله الوقود ومشكله تكلفه حتى
النزوح اليوم بسبب يعني حالات
الفقر المتزايده داخل السودان شكرا لك
سالم على كل حال سنبقى نتابع معك والزملاء
رصد الواقع من على الارض من الخرطوم شكرا
لك
تركوا الحرب وراءهم بحثا عن طريق للخروج
من السودان الاف الاشخاص من عشرات
الجنسيات غادروا للوصول الى بر الامان
وعبر وجهات مختلفه كثيرون وجدوا ما تسنى
لهم من وسائل مغادره السودان بحرا او جوا
في حين لجا اخرون للطريق الاصعب بقطع
الجغرافيا السودانيه برا للدول المجاوره
مفوضيه شؤون اللاجئين في تشاد اعلنت ان
عشرين الف لاجئ وصلوا الى هذا البلد مع
توقعات بان يتبعهم مئه الف اخرون في اسوا
الحالات اما في جنوب السودان فترجح
التقديرات الامميه نزوح ما يصل الى 170
الف شخص ثلاثه ارباعهم من لاجئ جنوب
السودان الذين سيعودون في رحله نزوح جديده
لكن في بلدهم هذه المره حتى من وجدوا
دولهم او دوله ثالثه تمد لهم يد العون فهم
يعانون الامرين لمغادره السودان في رحله
محفوفه بالمشاق تليها نقاط توقف مؤقته لمن
غادروا برا الى مصر او جوا الى جيبوتي او
بحرا عبر بورسودان وصولا الى السعوديه
العربيه
من ام درمان مشاهدينا ينضم
[موسيقى]
الينا كيف كيف هي الصوره من هناك خصوصا
اننا نتحدث عن نزوح داخلي وعن اجلاء خارجي
لو سمحت اذا امكن نقل الصوره
اهلا بك نعم هنالك حركه نزوح داخليه كبيره
في مناطق مختلفه من العاصمه الخرطوم وكذلك
الى الولايات المجاوره او المتاخمه
للعاصمه الخرطوم
وبالجزير بالذكر ان منطقه ام درمان تعتبر
واحده من المناطق التي يتجه اليها
النازحون او الخارجون من مناطق الاشتباك
الشديده الى طريق وهو الطريق الذي يربط
بمعبر اردين الى الى جمهوريه مصر هنالك
موقف شهير في غربي ام درمان يعرف بموقف
مصر تاتي اليه وفود يوميه بصوره كبيره جدا
هذا هذا ان تحدثنا عن حركه النزوح الى الى
الى الى مصر شمالا حتى داخل مدينه ام
درمان هنالك هنالك عائلات كثيره نزحت الى
المناطق
الطرفيه لام درمان وهي تعتبر هادئه نسبيا
وكذلك
الاحداث او الاحوال في هذا اليوم هنالك
هدون سبيت تماما في مدينه ام درمان في
مناطق مختلفه من ام درمان خاصه الناحيه
الشماليه وهي الناحيه التي شهدت الايام
الاولى فيها معارك عنيفه بين قوات الدعم
السريع والجيش السوداني لان هذه المنطقه
المنطقه الشماليه تضم مواقع استراتيجيه
للجيش السوداني ومعسكر لدعم السريع وعسكر
خالد بن الوليد والكليه الحربيه وكذلك
محطه قاعده وادي سيدنا العسكريه التي يتم
فيها اجلاء الاجانب من جنسيات مختلفه تقول
كما كما صرح الجيش السوداني في هذا البيان
مقداد ساعود الى النقطه الاولى وهي عمليه
النزوح نحو الحدود المصريه وعمليه الاجلاء
نحو الحدود المصريه قبل الازمه كنا نتحدث
عن حوالي
30 الف حافله يعني تقل الذين يذهبون
يذهبون الى القاهره والى العاصمه الخرطوم
اليوم هل هناك زياده بعدد الحافلات وماذا
عن نقاط التفتيش الجديده التي يعني
استحدثتها السلطات المصريه على الحدود بين
البلدين
نعم حركه النزوح الى دوله مصر نشطه كثيرا
بعد الاحداث الداميه هنالك حركه كبيره
واعداد مسافرين بمختلف المركبات الخاصه
والعامه والحافلات السفريه الكبيره هنالك
حركه نزوح كبيره باعداد كبيره جدا
والجديد بالذكر ان هذه الحركه لا تزداد
صعوبه مع الازمه الطاحنه في الوقود وكذلك
حتى شحفل في السيارات التي تقل المهاجرين
من وسط وسط ام درمان الى الى مصر هنالك
معبر ارجين وهو النقطه التي يتم فيها يتم
فيها كذلك اجراء التاشيرات الدخول
للمهاجرين في السودان وهنالك معابر اخرى
هنالك بالنسبه للشباب يقيمون في في مدينه
حلفا حتى تتم عمليات الدخول
وكذلك هنالك نقاط اخرى
ربما تصادفهم في في الطريق لان الطريق
طويل جدا
وكذلك المناطق
المتاخمه لهذا الطريق ربما هي يحدث فيها
انفلات امني اثناء مسيرهم الى مدينه حلفا
ومن ثم الى معبر ارقين واسوان
مقداد ايضا
بالرحله من العاصمه الخرطوم الى
المخارج تحديدا الى بورتسودان هناك الطريق
السريع الذي يربط هاتين المنطقتين نتحدث
عن حوالي 900 كيلومتر هذا الطريق هل يعني
هناك سيطره كامله للجيش عليه وام درمان
يعني ما هي صله الوصل هناك بين هذين
الوجهتين او هاتين الوجهتين
نعم الطريقه الغربي من ام درمان هنا ينطلق
الى الطريق مباشره الى الولايه الشماليه
اما هنالك يوجد طريق يذهب بمدينه عببره
وشندي ومن ثم الى هيا ومن ثم الى بورسودان
هذا الطريق
كما كما ان هنالك اتهامات بين قوات الدعم
السريع والجيش السوداني في امكانيه
السيطره على هذا الطريق لكن يعتبر امن
نسبيا هنالك كثير من البعثات الدبلوماسيه
وكثير من الرعايه الدول الاجنبيه ذهبوا من
هذا الطريق وتم اجلائهم برا الى تلك
المناطق وكذلك منطقه وادي سيدنا العسكريه
هي تعتبر من المناطق الاستراتيجيه التي تم
بها بجلاء الرعايه
عن طريق الطيران الحربي لدول مختلفه اما
فيما يتعلق بالوضع الامني في منطقه ام
درمان هنالك هدوء نسبي في هذا اليوم خاصه
هنالك حركه نسبيه للمواصلات في مناطق
البعيده عن الاشتباكات هنالك حركه نسبيه
في الاسواق التي تعتبر ايضا بعيده من
الاشتباكات في هذه الليله خاصه هنالك هدوء
ربما ان الهدنه دخلت حيز التنفيذ بصوره
جاده في هذه المنطقه شمالا هنالك استقرار
تام في في جميع المناطق ربما الاوقات
التاليه قد نشهد او لا نشهد اشتباكات
مختلفه لقوات الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني في ام درمان على كل حال مقداد
سنبقى نرصد معك الصوره من ام درمانا فور
ورود اي جديد شكرا لك الصحافه مقداد حسن
حدثتنا
تعاني مشاهدينا مشارح الخرطوم من ضعف
الساعه الاستعابيه بعدما ظلت الاف الجفا
من مكدسه فيها لاكثر من ثلاثه اعوام كما
وتهدد مخلفات الحرب من اكوام قمامه متفشله
في الشوارع من ازمتين صحيه وبيئيه قد
تتفشى اذا ما عالجت الدوله جمله ازماتها
عاجلا فلنتابعها
ملقون على جنبات الشوارع السودان منكبون
على ظهورهم او بطونهم لا فرق
هذا احد تقاطعات حي الحلفايه يلفظ جثثا
مرميه على الاطراف
لايام وما زالت اجسادهم تربك الطرقات
يمشون بجانبها متجاهلين ان انفاسها انقطعت
وبل من القصف يعرقل سبل نقل رفاتهم فالحي
منهم لا يجرؤ على الذهاب بجثامينهم الى
المشرحه لتكدوسها وايضا خشيه ان ترديه
رصاصه ظلت طريقها اليه فلا هدنه تفي
بالحياه
[موسيقى]
من هنا تنبعث رائحه موت اخر تفوح منه ازمه
صحيه وبيئيه ففي مستشفى الساحه مثلا يتجمع
الجرح من قوه الدعم السريع لكن الكادر
الطبي يعجز عن معالجه الاعداد المتزايده
من الاصابات استمرار نزف احدهم يشي بزياده
عدد القتلى وتضاف اليه عباره كارثيه لا
متسعه لمزيد من الجثث في مشارح الخرطوم
التي تكابد اعدادهم لثلاث سنوات
فمنها جثث تعفنت واخرى تحللت اما عن
رائحتها فحدث ولا حرج
مخلفات الحرب تهدد السودان وتضعه في
تحديات معقده فهناك نفايات بالاكوام
تتكاثر فيها فرص انتشار الامراض المعديه
والجرثوميه لتكاثر الحشرات والذباب حولها
وانبعاث الروائح الكريهه هي المصائب هكذا
لا تاتي فرادى على السودان حرب دروس محمله
بازمتين صحيه وبيئيه اسراء الصغير العربيه
مشاهدينا ساتابع واياكم هذه الصور التي
وردتنا قبل قليل لاطلاق سراح المساجين من
سجن الاندلس جنوبي الخرطوم فلنتابع
امام القسم مدينه العمل
مساجين مدينه الامل
تم اطلاق سراحهم الان
مدينه الامل
من امام
من امام القسم مدينه العمل
مساجين مدينه الامل
تم اطلاق سراحهم الان
مدينه الامل
من امام القسم
من امام القسم مدينه الامل
دينا تبعنا هذه الصور لعمليه اطلاق سراح
مساجين من سجن الاندلس جنوبي الخرطوم
للتفكير هي ثاني عمليه اطلاق لمساجين قبل
ايام شهدنا عمليات اطلاق المساجين من سجن
ام درمان واليوم من هذا السجل بالانتقال
الى شقه اخر وتحديدا الى الموقف الامريكي
والى يعني الجهد الامريكيه الذي ينصب
بالساعات الماضيه حول بدايه هدنه وثانيا
حل سياسي داخل الخرطوم ينضم الي من دبي
عبر زوم صموئيل المتحدث الاقليمي باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه بدايه اسمح للسيد
سامويل ان ابدا من موضوع الاجلاء اجلاء
الرعايه الامريكيين تحديدا من الخرطوم هل
يعني
اتميتم العمليه الاولى وهي اجلاء الرسميين
والدبلوماسيين وماذا عن المواطنين نحن
نتحدث عن مواطنين يحملون الجنسيه مزدوجه
حوالي 16 الف مواطن
اذا مساء الخير يا استاذ ليان وشكرا لك
وشكرا لكنه العربيه الاستضافه وبدون شك من
الاولويه المهمه في الولايات المتحده
حمايه المواطنين الامريكيين كما راينا منذ
ايام قمنا باجلاء دبلوماسيين والان نحن
نركز على المواطنين الملكين نحن في تواصل
معهم نحن فتاه المكاتب في واشنطن وفي
اماكن اخرى في المنطقه لنكون في تواصل
معهم نحن الان نتكلم مع كل الشركاء وحلفاء
لديهم الامكانيه لاجلاء بعد المواطنين
الملكين من بورسعيد نحن ارسلنا سفون بحريه
للبورسعيد والان نحن نقوم بمراقبه الجو
الاماكن الجويه فوق الطرق من الخرطوم الى
بورسعيد ولازم نشكر المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لان المملكه العربيه السعوديه
منذ ايام يبدو ان كل دول اخرى ليس فقط
المتحده ولكن كل دول اخرى
تحدث هذول المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بالنسبه هذه الالمانيه اذا نحن في تواصل
مع المملكه مع كل الدول الاخرى ونحن
سنستمر في حمايه المواطنين المالكيين بدون
كان هناك يعني
استفسار رسمي غير يعني غير ما كتب
بالجرائد او بالصحف الامريكيه
اذا بشكل عام يا بشكل عام
لا تؤكد ابدا على عدد من المواطنين لان
اولا ليس لدينا اي قانون الذي يفرض على
الامريكيين لتقوم بتسجيل مع السفاره
الامريكيه للقنصليه او الحكومه الملكيه
الملكيه لديهم الحريه للسفر ولا نخب
المواطنين الامريكيين
الزام
لسجل معنا اذا لدينا فكره عامه لدينا فكره
عامه ان هناك ممكن الاف من الملكين ولكن
رقم بالضبط والعدل بزبط ليس لدينا لذلك
نحن نطلب
الامريكيين ليكونوا في تواصل معنا ولكن ان
نذكر هنا ان منذ سنوات كنا لدينا تعذيرات
ضد اي سفر من اي مواطنين الملكين للسودان
بشكل عام الولايات المتحده نعم نحن سنبذل
كل ما في وسائنا لاجل او لنقدم المساعده
للهؤلاء الملكين الذين يريدوا ان يغادروا
السودان
اسمح لي ان اذكر بان وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه قالت للعربيه بان الولايات
المتحده تواصل الضغط او على من اجل تمديد
وقف اطلاق النار في السودان واضافت
الخارجيه الامريكيه انها تنسق مع شركاء
اقليميين ودوليين للمساعده في تشكيل لجنه
للاشراف على المفاوضات مشيره الى انها
تسعى لمساعده الفصائل المتحاربه لتحديد
مسار لوقف دائم للاعمال العدائيه وذلك عبر
اتصال مع القاده العسكريين والمدنيين
بالحديث عن تمديد الهدنه ان كان هناك
اتصال من وزير الخارجيه الامريكي بالساعات
الماضيه بين طرفي النزاع وتم الاتفاق على
هدنه لثلاثه ايام ما المسار المقبل بعد
هذه الهدنه
ركز على كل يوم وانا لا اريد ان استبرق
ماذا سيحدث بكره وبعد بكره لان نحن مازال
خلال هذا الوقت الحرش ووقت صعب ولذلك لازم
نركز اليوم في هذه الليله على استمرار وقف
اطلاق النار ليس في اماكن معينه ولكن في
كل انهاء البلد في كل انها مدينه الخرطوم
وفي اي اماكن اخرى داخل السودان اذا لازم
نحث كل الاطراف لتطبيق وتنفيذ هذه الهدنه
وتنطيدها الى ثلاث الايام ونحن نتمنى ان
هذه الهدنه ستمتد بعد ثلاثه ايام اذن الان
كما ذكرتي في تقرير نحن في تواصل مع كل
اطراف داخل السودان وانما نقول كل اطراف
ليس فقط الاطراف العسكريه او الاطراف التي
الان تمارس الانف ضد سودان لا من اللازم
من الان نبدا مع الحوار والتواصل مع الاط
سياسيه المجتمع المدني بان ساعود للحديث
عن هذه النقطه التواصل مع المجتمع المدني
ومع المجتمع العسكري ولكن يعني منذ بدايه
هذه الازمه ومنذ بدايه هذا الصراع يعني
تواصلتم مع طرفي النزاع الى اكثر من هدنه
وفي كل مره كانت الهدنه الاخرى ولا يتم
الالتزام بها من قبل الطرفين ما الضمانات
التي ممكن ان يعني تعطوها اليوم او يعطيها
الجانبان للامريكيين بانهم سيلتزمون بهذه
الهدنه اذن سؤال الاساسي هنا يا ليال ليس
الضمانات التي سيقدم الاطراف السودانيه
للمالكيين او اي طرف خرج من السودان لا ما
هي الضمانات التي هذه الاطراف السودانيه
ستقدم للشعب السوداني اذا نعم نعم نحن من
جانب الامريكي لدينا اهتمام لدينا تركيز
نحن منخرطين هل ممكن ان يكون الضغط
بالموضوع الاقتصادي المالي بما ان يعني
السودان اليوم بحاجه لمساعده المؤسسات
الماليه الدوليه او بموضوع العقوبات هي
يعني السيف الذي ممكن ان يستعمل بالضغط
على افريقيا الصراع
لدينا كل هذه هذا لدينا كل هذه الادوات كل
هذه الادوات كل هذه الطرق متاحه علينا
ولكن الان من المبكر ان دخل في اي فرديات
بالنسبه فرض عقوبات او تصنيف اي كيانات
جديده على لائحه العقوبات نريد ان نركز
اليوم على تنفيذ والتطبيق هذه الهدنه
والتمديد هذه الهدنه
اسمح لي ان ننتقل الى تقرير لصحيفه
حيث قالت الصحيفه بان الاداره الامريكيه
فاشله بعمليه الانتقال الديمقراطي في
السودان بعدما حفزت المنافسه بين طرفي
الصراع في البلاد فلنتابع التفاصيل واعود
اليك لمناقشه هذا التقرير
عمليه التحول الديمقراطي والانتقال للحكم
المدني في السودان فشلت وانتهت بالفوضى
وبوادر حرب اهليه والسبب الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تقول صحيفه وولز جورنال الصحيفه
اعتبرت ان واشنطن اخطات في قراءه الوضع
السياسي في الخرطوم وحفزت المنافسه بين
رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني قائد الجيش
عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد قوات الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان دقلو المعروف بحمدتي
على بناء قوتيهما وتحديدا بعد تبني سياسه
اصلاح قطاع الامن في السودان بما يضمن وضع
الرجلين تحت السيطره المدنيه وهذا الامر
لم تصدقه الا واشنطن تقول الصحيفه
الامريكيه منذ الاستقلال عام
1956 شهد السودان سبعه عشره انقلاب نجحت
منها سته وحربين اهليتين وصراع اباده
جماعيه في دارفور ورغم هذا لم تقرا واشنطن
جيدا المشهد السياسي في السودان مما ادى
الى اتجاه البلاد نحو الانهيار ومعها
العمليه الديمقراطيه التي دعمتها واشنطن
منذ الاطاحه بالرئيس السابق عمر البشير
عام 2019
ابعد من ذلك فشلوا الحسابات السياسيه
للاداره الامريكيه ادى الى جذب انتباه
روسيا والصين حيث تعتبر السودان ارض الذهب
والنفط والموارد المعدنيه الاخرى وربما
لاجل كل هذه التشابات حذر الامين العام
للامم المتحده من ان الصراع في السودان قد
يبتلع المنطقه كلها محاسن حداره العربيه
اعود اليك سيد يعني اخطاتم في قراءه
الواقع السياسي زرعتم الفتنه بين الاطراف
تبنيتم اطراف من المجتمع المدني على حساب
اطراف اخرى وايضا الاستمات لاعاده هيكله
مؤسسات الدوله
المؤسسات طبعا العسكريه
والاخرى كل هذه الاخطاء التي يحملكم اياها
اليوم ان كان الراي العام الامريكي او حتى
يعني الراي العام السياسي العالمي كيف
تردون عليه
اذا اذا الجريله الواصله تريد ان
ترى الولد متحده
تسيطر وتفرد ايراداتها على الشعب السوداني
وتمارس السيطره على دوله اخرى ولا تحترموا
هذا الراي موجود
فقط هو موجود عند يعني كثيرين اليوم من
الراي الاخر الذي يحمل حتى دخل السودان
يعني كثير من المحللين من الرسميين حملوكم
المسؤوليه انتم والمجتمع الاممي بما الت
اليه الاوضاع في السودان اليوم
كما كنت اقول يا استاذه ليال اذا اي طرف
اخر
داخل ولد المتحده ولا خرج من ولد متحده
لديها هذه الرؤيه هذا الوجه النظر التي
تقول ان من الازمه الاوليه المتحده تاخذ
السيطره او لا تحترم السياده دول اخرى هذا
وجهه نظره ولكن من وجهه نظر هذه الاداره
هذه الاداره تحترم سياده الدوله وهذه
الاداره ترى ان الغذاء في السودان سيء جدا
وبدلا من نلقى اللوم على جيد جدا
منهم
يفعلون هذا القتال الان ليس الولد المتحده
ليس الدوله الخليجيه ليس الامم المتحده
ليس الدوله الاوروبيه ليست مصر ليس
اثيوبيا لا الجيش السوداني وقوه الدعم
السريه وكلهم سودانيين
في نهايه المطاف ما الحل اليوم ما الحل
اليوم اذا كان عبر الاليه الثلاثيه
والاليه الرباعيه ثلاث سنوات من عمر يعني
البعثه الاماميه واربع سنوات من عمر
الانتقال ولم يتم الانتقال الديمقراطي
اليوم مع الاقتتال الحاصل كيف يمكن ان
يكون الحال داخل السودان
اذا نحن نرى ان الخطوه الاولى الخطوه
الاولى خذنا الخطوه الاولى ووقف اطلاق
النار نعم نريد ان نستانف ونريد ان نرى
استانف العمليه السياسيه الانتقاليه الى
الديمقراطيه نريد ان نرى حكومه حد قياده
المدنيين نريد نرى المجتمع المدني داخل
السودان ولكن ليون في هذه الليله في
الشاشه في كل الشاشات التلفزيونيه الاخرى
نحن نرى القتال والانف اذا من اللازم انه
نركز اولا وفي هذه اللحظه على الهدنه على
وقف اطلاق نار والى هذا الهدنه تمتد على
اقل يوم ولا يومين نعم من الممكن ان ندخل
في هذه العمليه الجديده التي كان يتكلم
عليها الوزير بلينكل بالنسبه اللجنه
لاشراف على هذه الهدنه وهذه اللجنه لازم
تتكون من كل الاطراف السودانيه ليس فقط
الجيش السوداني وقوه الدعم السريع اين
الاصوات المجتمع المدني اين السياسيين
وقاده في المجتمع المدني اذا من اللازمن
ان نشمل هؤلاء هذه اللجنه وهذه العمليه
وايضا من اللازم ان نقوم بكل ذلك بتنسيق
مع كل دور المعنيه منها الخليجيه والدوله
المجاوره والامم فقط
انتم تعولون على دور دور اقليمي غربي اممي
مع الدور الامريكي للوصول الى حل داخل
السودان شكرا لك عبرز محدثتنا سامويل
المتحدث الاقليمي باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
من دبي
وسط مساعد دول في اجلاء رعاياها من
السودان بما فيها الولايات المتحده يعاد
للذاكره التجربه الامريكيه في افغانستان
تجربه تختلف تماما عن السودان لما تواجهه
واشنطن اليوم من تحديات امنيه كبيره
لاجلاء ما يقدر 16,000 امريكي فلنتابع
وسط هموم السودان تبرز معضله للدول الرغبه
في اجلاء مواطنيها وخاصه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
تجربه افغانستان لا يمكن ان تعاد بالنسبه
لواشنطن كان الاجلاء من مطار كابول ممكنا
كونه تحت السيطره الامريكيه اما في
السودان فالوضع مختلف الطائرات حرقانه
بالكامل حال المطارات هنا لا يساعد مطار
الخرطوم تحت القصف المستمر وباقي المطارات
لا تخلو من المشكلات وربما هذا ما دفع
البيت الابيض للاقرار بالحقيقه
تجربه نقل الدبلوماسيين باعدادهم المحدوده
كانت ممكنه لكن الطريقه ذاته لم يكن ممهدا
امام نقل مدنيين متفرقين باعداد هائله وسط
هدن لا سلام فيها فلا اخلاء دون وقف طويل
لاطلاق النار لضمان سلامه المدنيين خطه
نقل جماعي برا هذا ما تدرسه وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه لنقل مواطنيها من الخرطوم فبعد
قصف متبادل لا ينقطع في محيط المطارات
تستخدم امريكا قدراتها الاستخباراتيه في
مراقبه الطرق وتوقع التهديدات الناجمه عن
اجلاء بري محتمل
الطريق الى ارجين البري الحدود السودانيه
المصريه طريق بري عرضه 80 مترا على بعد
850 كيلو مترا من العاصمه الخرطوم شمالا
خطه تصطدم بتحديات امنيه كبيره خلال نقل
المواطنين الامريكيين من السودان الى مصر
طريق بري اخر وصولا الى ميناء بورتسودان
البوابه الشرقيه للسودان تبعد عن العاصمه
الخرطوم مسافه
675 كيلومترا نشرت امريكا سفونا فيها
كبديل اخر لاجلاء مواطنيها عبر البحر
الاحمر تضع امريكا خططا بديله قيد الدراسه
لنقل 16,000 امريكي في السودان وسط معركه
تتعقد ساعه بعد اخرى وهدى تتوالى لم يكتب
لاي منها الصمود غذاء السالم العربيه
[موسيقى]
اعرب رئيس مجموعه البنك الدولي عن شكره
للعاهل السعودي الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز
على اسهام المملكه ومساعدتها في اجلاء
منسوبي البنك من السودان الى المملكه
وثمنا في خطاب بعثه للملك سلمان كما عبر
عن شكره لسفاره المملكه لدى جمهوريه
السودان ومنسوبيها على الرعايه والاهتمام
لمنسوبي البنك وعائلاتهم الذي كان له
الاثر الكبير في ظل هذه الازمه
قالت وزاره الخارجيه الالمانيه انها لا
تخطط للمزيد من رحلات الاجلاء الالمانيه
من السودان مشيره الى ان اخر رحله اجلاء
من السودان الى الاردن ستنطلق مساء اليوم
واوضحت الخارجيه الالمانيه ان دولا شريكه
ستتولى اجلاء المواطنين الالمان المتبقين
في السودان خلال الايام المقبله
اعلنت هيئه اركان الجيوش الفرنسيه عن
انهائها عمليات الاجلاء نحو جيبوتي وانها
ابقت على فرقاتها في بورت سودان لمساعده
الامم المتحده على عمليات الاجلاء نحو جده
كما اكدت وزاراتها الخارجيه والدفاع
الفرنسيه في بيان مشترك ان عدد الجنسيات
التي استفادت من عمليات الاجلاء الفرنسيه
ارتفع الى 41 جنسيه واشار البيان ايضا الى
ان عمليات الاجلاء حصلت من نقاط التجمع في
الخرطوم نحو قاعده وادي سيدنا ومن القاعده
جوا الى جيبوتي
استنفار دبلوماسي في شتى الدول الاثر
اشتباكات السودان
عمليه اجلاء الرعايه على قدم وساق
الولايات المتحده اجلت 100 شخص بثلاث
مروحيات حلقت من جيبوتي مرورا باثيوبيا
وصولا الى السودان مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه
والامنيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل
قال ان اكثر من الف من رعايانا غاده
السودان فرنسا اجلت ما يقارب
538 فردا بينهم اوروبيون وافارقه اما
ايطاليا فاغلقت سفارتها في الخرطوم وطلبت
من 200 شخص تركى الاراضي السودانيه في حين
تنتظر المانيا وصول طائره رابعه للاجلاء
مع ايصال 500 شخص الى بر الامان واجلت
طائره اسبانيه 100 شخص بينهم 30 اسبانيا
و70 من اوروبا وامريكا اللاتينيه
وايرلندا بواقع 150 شخصا كما تم اجلاء نحو
25 نمساويا
وتسعه رومانيين وخمسه مجريين وواحد وعشرين
بلغاريا بمساعده دول اخرى
من القاهره
السياسي السوداني عادل ابراهيم حمد استاذ
عادل سابدا من النقطه التي يعني بدا
الافرقه الدوليين
اثاره بالساعات الماضيه وهو موضوع تفكيك
السودان الروسي يقولون بان هناك مصلحه
امريكيه والامريكيين يقولون العكس من له
مصلحه اليوم بتقسيم السودان وتفكيكه
الذهاب الى
تقسيم السودان هذا
تعيين بامر لا تبدو ملامحه واضحه في الوقت
الحالي واعتقد ان ذلك نوع من الموالاه في
التشاؤم في في نظري المستقبل السودان
الان مشكله السودان هي موضوع
التعثر في الانتقال الديمقراطي اما الحديث
عن ما عادات اخرى في هذه مغالاه كما اسلف
وارى ان موضوع التعثر الديمقراطي في
الانتقال الديمقراطي هو الامر الذي يجب ان
يكون التركيز عليه
وخاصه انه تم الاشاره الى ذلك الى هذه
النقطه في الحديث عن فشل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في هذه الناحيه
وهذا ليس بمستغرب لانه كثير من المراقبين
وكثير منها حتى السياسيين السودانيين
يعاونون كثيرا على الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه او بريطانيا باعتبارهما دولتان
لهم تجاري في مساله
الديمقراطيه وهم من رواد الديمقراطيه على
المستوى الدولي
ولكن لابد من التمييز بين النجاح دوله في
ارساء دعائم الديمقراطيه في مجتمعات داخلي
وجهود هذه الدوله في التبشير ونشر هذه
الثقافه خارج حدودها قد تنجح دوله في
ارساء الدعائم الديمقراطيه في داخل حدودها
ولكن ليس بذور ان تكون هذه دوله مؤهل
الديمقراطيه داخل
السودان اليوم
يعني وجهه نظر سائده بانه بظل هذا
الاقتتال الغير معلوم ومحسوب العواقب ولا
الامد هناك يعني نظره تشاؤميه حول موضوع
الانتقال المسار الديمقراطي والانتقال الى
السلطه المدنيه وبان هذا الموضوع اصبح
يعني طويل الامد ولا يمكن الحديث عنه
باشهر او حتى بسنوات هل توافق على هذه
الوجهات النظر
لا واثقه قد لا اوافق لان السودان السودان
تجارب في في ماضي قريب هنا
الشعب سينجح مرتين في الاطاحه بانظمه
الفاتوريه
وقدمت
ديمقراطي وهي فترات انتقاليه قصيره العمر
تعقبها انتخابات يختار من خلالها الشعب
حكومه المدنيه المنتخبه هذه الوصفه تعرضت
في الطيبه الاخيره الى تعقيد غير مبرر غير
مبرر قطع اسهمت فيه ايضا عن الروائيه
والثلاثيه بين الرباعي الولايات المتحده
وبرضايه رقم تجاربهم والعظيمه في
الديمقراطيه هذه
الوصفه الوصفه هي الانتقال من
الحكم الديكتاتوري الى الى حكومه
ديمقراطيه عبر الانتخابات الاليه المتفق
عليها في السودان او عالميا هي الانتخابات
ولكن انتخابات
لامر ما تعرضت لسبب او لاخر تعرض لنوع من
التعقيد
والتنكؤتى التحكم وذم تجري الانتخابات رغم
انها هي الوصفه البسيطه في بعض الاحيان في
بعض الاحيان
يدعي البعض ان الوصفه البسيطه هي قرين
للفشل ولابد من تعقيد ما حتى تبدو حتى
يبدو الحل على اكثر يعني الوصفه الجديده
جاهزه وهي غير مقبوله حتى عند اطراف
النزاع شكرا لك لو
سمحت ليكون هذه الفكره انتهى الوقت
باختصار دعيني
باختصار باختصار الخطوات اولا الاعتراض
بجيش واحد موحد ثانيا الذهاب فورا
انتخابات ديمقراطيه حتى لا تكون الاتهام
فقط للجيش بانه متغول على السلطه
السياسيه فلابد ان يكون لا وجود عسكريه في
العمليه السياسيه ولا وجود لقوه مدنيه غير
مصوره شعبيه وكنتم هذه الازمه شكرا لك
استاذ على هذه المداخله
افاد تقرير مشاهدينا لصحيفه الجارديان
البريطانيه بان المنظمات الامميه
والحكومات الغربيه صدمت من التطورات
الدمويه في السودان فالنتابع
كل الاضواء الحمراء اومضت منذره بالحرب في
السودان لكن لا الامم المتحده ولا القوى
الفاعله راى ذلك بل على العكس تماما نتيجه
رصدتها صحيفه الجاردن البريطانيه في صدمه
الدبلوماسيين الغربيين مما الت اليه
الاوضاع في السودان اللافت ان المبعوث
الاممي للسودان فولكر بيرس رد نافيا على
استفسارات الموظفين الامميين حول وجود
تحذير مبكرا للحرب اول شيء انا بطاقه وفي
لقاء مع العربيه والحدث نهايه الشهر
الماضي كان له راي اخر لم يستبعد فيه
السيناريو الاسوا هل ترى ان الحل اقرب اما
المواجهه اقرب الحل اقرب بكثير المواجهه
طبعا سيناريو ولكن مش ارجح السيناريوهات
انا مازلت متفائلا فيما كان بيرت متفائلا
كانت منذ تصعيد بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريعه تحشيد وتامين للذخيره وتجنيد
وتامين وقود وامدادات حتى الطبيه وفق
الجاردن
داخليا لم تخفى تلك التحركات على الاطراف
فحاكموا اقليم دارفور مني اركو منوي حذر
في مارس الماضي من الحرب وحث الطرفين على
عدم القتال في المدن قراءات اخرى يبدو
انها اربكت المشهد فالبعض اطمئن للموقف
الامريكي الذي لم يصدر اي تحذيرات
غير ان المشهد الان معاكس تماما وصادم
والمخاوف تتعاظم من انجرار البلاد الى حرب
اهليه طاحنه
مشاهدينا عوده لنقل المشهد من على الارض
من بورسودان ينضم الينا الصحافه عبد
القادر بكاش عبد القادر كيف هي الصوره من
هناك عمليات الاجلاء لمواطنين الذين يعني
تم اجلاءهم من الخرطوم وصولا الى بورسودان
كيف تتم التفاصيل لو سمحت
انا الان في نادي حيه الموالي البحريه في
السودان في مدينه بورسودان للساحل
السوداني حيث يجري عمليات الاجلاء
والترتيبات من اللجنه الحكوميه
وبالتنسيق مع السفاره السعوديه
لايلاء الرعايه هناك عدد كبير جدا من
رعايه الدول العربيه والاوروبيه والاسيويه
والاسلاميه جميعهم الان موجودون ويعملون
في تكمله اجراءاتهم الهجريه هناك تسهيلات
تمت من الجانب السوداني ومن الجانب
السعودي وتجد العمليات حتى الان وهناك
كثير من الاسره التي لم تجد معها في داخل
الفنادق والشرطه والبندقيه في مدينه
بورسودان الان رابط داخل النادي في انتظار
اجراءات التكمل الاجراءاتها
للسماحله بالسفر هناك تجهيز ظهري عالي
المستوى من الحكومه السعوديه في بورسودان
الان حتى الذين
اشكالات في الجوازات من الرعايه العرب تم
تجهيز اجراءاتهم وتسهيلها ليتمكنوا من
المغادره بشكل سليم حتى الان الامور تمضي
بثلاثه عاليه وهناك تنسيق واجراءات
ورئيس اللجنه العليا
الحكوميه السودانيه اللواء صلاح الان داخل
النادي يشرف بنفسه وهناك مساعده السفير
يشرف بنفسه على عمليات الاجلاء والوقوف
والاطمئنان على التركيبات هناك مساء اليوم
تم التفويج او يعني اجلاء حوالي 61 من
التنين بالتنكر وقود وصل الى مدينه
بورسودان تنكر صيني تم التنسيق بينه وبين
السفاره
61 تم اجلائهم قبل قليل من ميناء بورسودان
حتى قبل التفريق شهدته من الوقود
اجلى 61 الى ميناء جده سيعود مره اخرى الى
مدينه بورسودان لتفريق مولته من الوقود
شكرا لك الصحافه عبد القادر بكاش حدثتنا
من بورت
نتابع معكم مشاهدينا هذا الفيديو الخاص
العربيه لتشول قوات الدعم السريع في شارع
بالقرب من مناطق الاشتباكات كما تظهر
اللقطات المحاله التجاريه مغلقه في
المدينه
[موسيقى]
والان مشاهدينا الى موجز لابرز الاخبار
اعلن نائب وزير الدفاع البريطانيه ان
بلاده ارسلت الى كييف الاف القذائف
لدبابات تشالنجر 2 من بينها قذائف
يورانيوم منظم قال ايضا بان وزاره الدفاع
لا تتعقب الاماكن التي تستخدم فيها القوات
المسلحه او تستخدم فيها القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه ذخيره اليورانيوم المنظم
هذا واعلنت مشاهدينا وزاره الخارجيه
السويديه طردها لخمسه مسؤولين في السفاره
الروسيه في السويد وذلك بسبب قيامهم
بانشطه لا تتوافق مع اتفاقيه فيينا
للعلاقات الدبلوماسيه فيما لم تحدد
الوزاره طبيعه هذه الانشطه في المقابل
اعلنت الخارجيه الروسيه طرد موظف في سفاره
مولدوفا في اطار المعامله بالمثل حيث تم
استدعاء السفير فوق العاده والمفوض
لجمهوريه مولدوفا لدى روسيا وقدمت له
مذكره احتجاج على اجراءات مولدوفا غير
الوديه تجاه روسيا
وايضا دعا وزير الخارج الروسي الامين
العام للامم المتحده انطونيو غوتيريوس الى
الى اهتمام بعمليه التسويه في الشرق
الاوسط بما في ذلك اللجنه الرباعيه التي
قال عنها انها اصبحت ضحيه للوسطاء
الدوليين مثل الولايات المتحده والاتحاد
الاوروبي في المقابل اكد منسق الامم
المتحده الخاص لعمليه السلام في الشرق
الاوسط على عدم شرعيه المستوطنات
الاسرائيليه بالاراضي الفلسطينيه بموجب
القانون الدولي وانها تشكل عقبه كبيره في
طريق السلام بين الجانبين الفلسطيني
والاسرائيلي
اجرى وزير الدفاع الروسي سرقه محادثات
رباعيه في موسكو مع نظرائه ايران وروسيا
وسوريا وتركيا وقالت وزاره الدفاع التركيه
ان الوزراء ناقشوا خلال الاجتماع تعزيز
الامن في سوريا وتطبيع العلاقات بينها
وبين تركيا في المقابل نقلت صحيفه الوطن
السوريه عن مصدر لم تسميه القول ان له لا
صحه للبيان الذي بثته وزاره الدفاع
التركيه والذي تحدث عن خطوات ملموسه تتعلق
بتطبيع العلاقات بين تركيا وسوريا
وفي سوريا ايضا اعلنت قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه مقتل احد عناصرها بعد تعرض
سياره القتيل لقصف من طيران مسير تركي في
منطقه كوباني شماليه البلاد بدوره افاد
المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان بمقتل شخصين
واصابه ثالث بجراح خطيره جراء استهداف
طائره مسيره تركيا جنوب كوباني والتي تقع
ضمن مناطق سيطره قصد في ريف حلب الشرقي
مشاهدينا بهذه الاخبار المتفرقه اختم معكم
هذه الساعه الاخباريه لكن تغطيه العربيه
مستمره للتطورات في السودان والان الى
ساعه جديده مع الزميل طاهر بركه الى
اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات